I would imagine we're pushing over well
over, 1500 signs our electricity bill at
the moment is roughly around about
£1,000 each a month I'm just a holder
and not a collector
holding is an understatement bul signs
Amusement signs metal signs enamel signs
road signs signs signs signs neon neon
neon when you're working with neon all
you need is
love hidden in London's East End lies
God's Own junkyard and Aladdin's Cave of
neon here they produce display and sell
some of the most famous neon in the
world it's Run by One family Brothers
Marcus and Matthew and their mother
Linda and you might recognize a few from
your favorite movies Batman we worked on
that was 13 years old B six times Tomb
Raider three times Judge Dread the same
the list goes on and on and on Mission
Impossible you did didn't you yeah with
Tom Cruz yeah you know the bit when they
winched down I was actually above him
during that 17 years old on set Blade
Runner we got the dragon over there
Expendables we just did that not long
ago Superman 4 with Christopher Reeves
and our youngest son Max he actually
play made the baby super baby was he was
it was super baby Eyes Wide Shut we
worked with Stanley kick and uh we ended
up doing the back lot we filled this New
York streets with fairy lights neon
lights it was fantastic then on Friday
night one night we ended up having a
curry with him cuz we worked late till
about 12:00 at night doing a lighting
test on his like rainbow tuxedo sign
which was beautiful that was like the
primary part of the start of the film
they chose me to drive a yellow taxi big
New York taxi and drop him off outside
the rainbow tuxedo shop and you just get
a little glimpse of me driving him down
the film set and dropping him off you do
feel proud because it neon is usually
quite a big part of the the whole set so
it kind of gives atmosphere it's nice to
see that the work we're doing with our
hands and all the Blood Sweat and Tears
that we put into it goes into so so
amazing the other thing I think which is
nice is that it's
immortalized yeah you see it's there
forever yeah this establishment's
legendary Legacy can be credited to one
man the late Christopher bracie and his
family continue his work to this day
Chris was some inspirational to many of
people wasn't just me the locals people
in London I was amazed on his his
vision he is like the Godfather of neon
they say the neon man yeah within the
industry they call him industry yeah he
wanted to take neon to a higher purpose
he was working with his father dick
bracie who who started the business in
1952 but he saw further than just the
graphics on a sign he wanted to make
them Arty when he was younger he went to
see an exhibition by Dan flaven and also
was inspired by Bruce nman who was a 60s
neon artist that took him down a path
that think that signs were not just for
commercial use he could use neon as an
art medium as well everything was about
duel meanings it never just meant what
you read or what you thought it was it
was proper art you'd stand you could
look at it for hours and you still might
not actually work out what he's trying
to say it was kind of Chris's dream that
um one day we would be able to put it
all out on display and show it to the
public and he was quite specific about
it that it was for free Chris's dream
became a reality but the place needed a
name as iconic as his Neon Chris was
sitting at the desk one evening he
shouts out Euphoria you know um I've um
I've got a name and he said it was God's
Own junkyard he was looking at an
article by an American architect called
Peter Blake and he was actually saying
that uh all the Big Sky signs Motel
signs gas station signs mainly through
Route 66 were making God's own country
into God's Own
junkyard and Chris just said great
that's it fantastic that's us Chris's
work can still be seen around the
Streets of London but over the years the
demand for neon has fallen as shop
fronts and street corners off for new
attack like
LED I think that neon signs uh
to some extent will become rare there's
only one neon powder company left in the
world making the powders for the glass
so if they don't make the powder you
can't get these different colors what
everyone's saying is that neon signs are
going to be worth more money than
gold in about 10 years we could be
sitting on a gold mine making these
one-off signs isn't a walk in the park
each one takes hours of love and craft
it's a fragile product that you've got
to be careful with it's not something
that you can throw around whoever you've
got working with you on it has to be
very careful with it has to learn how to
handle neon the colors and the matching
of colors and the the the way colors can
mean something in what you're portraying
it's really something that you you think
about a lot don't you as as things are
being put together I always say that
neon is our favorite color you gradually
work your way up from from little
drawings and sketches up into s full
scale drawings once you've drawn that up
and you're happy with it you um take it
into the glass up we Bend these pure
sodium straight canes of glass which are
made from Sand so we basically bend over
th000 Dee burners these bits of glass we
actually Inlet the gases in the Arun or
the Neon gas which we're breathing in
now it's a pure gas and then we charge
it with voltage and then obviously we're
there you've got that set
when you charge that sign up you go wow
it's alive cuz sometimes it can fail it
can have a crack in it you know you can
overheat the glass it sort of dies on
you and you got to start a game but it's
yeah you get a Bast you do get a charge
yourself it's no surprise that God's Own
junkyard has a long list of famous fans
from around the world Jamie I love Lady
Gaga Jude La there's a lot of alist
stars that come in and we create in
designed for them maxel Rose eraser Finn
Lizzy they've all had pieces made up and
specially made for themselves as well as
well as hiring the place for their promo
or video shoots too we also did the
party for and John we filled the garden
didn't we with neon sign as they walked
in yeah it looked amazing and then hid
behind the bushes yeah yeah yeah we had
hide behind the bushes didn't we yeah
yeah we weren't high profile yeah
no when I look at what some of these
sign really look like and what the
impact and the presence of them being
there on buildings it's fantastic God's
Own junkyard is to some extent a labor
of love yeah the generic scale of it
just sort of like blows people away it's
just nice to see parts of still parts of
London that you know traditionally got
on signs up and working and they look
[Music]
fantastic